je suis de l'uap est apte je suis fier
de vous annoncer que le comté de yei d'
une usine à chiens en moins dont ils
doivent pas occuper le ap à une des
organisations les plus distingués du
pays je t'assure c'est quelque chose en
quoi je crois
sans ces deniers le louer il élève des
chiens de chasse ce dont on a réellement
besoin ce sont des photos des vidéos des
preuves de négligence c'est une preuve
de confiance moment oui peuvent assurer
la sécurité
chérie voici une autre nouvelle
stagiaire ça je vous donne une journée
vous êtes à l'essai merci lorsque
quelqu'un préfère acheter à un chien
d'élevage plutôt que de l'adopter dans
un refuge ça retire un animal son foyer
une chance d'être adoptés rien n'est
tout blanc ou tout noir chéri dit là bas
y'a quoi rien qui te concerne tu veux
voir un truc cool est magnifique
tu veux qu'on est en ville avec demain
continuez comme ça j'ai besoin d'une
dernière preuve et je tiendrai un mandat
on va finir par les avoir de quoi s
combattu et ce exactement elle prétend
sans vers des animaux domestiques ils
sont dit que les conditions étaient
déplorables tout ça c'est faux c'est
quoi ton problème dont seul but 7
freiner l'exploitation animale
ça suffit on à la situation en main or
loin s'en faut
alors pour qui tu travailles tu suis
vraiment désolé note en battant et
l'effet que tu défends donc il un
quelconque rapport avec ta relation avec
le fils de l'eau et non je me suis pas
engagée pour ça
l'organisation est la seule chose qui
importe
de quel côté qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
pour gagner alors
si je devais le refaire je referais nous
voilà donc un acte d'un individu et
pluviaux l'objection
si je ne fais rien je serais incapable
de me le pardonner